you just need to get drunk and go
dancing you'll forget all about jason
can you get drunk not really although if
i stand next to a powerful array of
magnets i do get pretty loopy do that
pop a couple magnets listen to some no
doubt dye your hair you'll be totally
fine in like two seconds i mean honestly
the best move is to get another dude and
just go to town
rebound guy but i guess here your
options are pretty limited what about
michael extraordinarily bad idea yeah
right forget it but
you don't need to worry you're awesome
you contain all the knowledge in the
universe you have a rip and bod and you
can literally do anything
this is just a blip
so was it helpful yes eleanor told me
that instead of being sad i should go
get it girl so i'm going to go get it
girl good what unclear look at
everything just to be safe and i should
be able to avoid glitches by watching
what i say around jason and tahani ah
thank you for your help i'm so glad
we're friends
me too and since we're friends i can
tell you this honestly take that outfit
out of rotation it makes you look bottom
heavy it does doesn't it ah
if it's okay with you i'm gonna go to my
void for a little while
i just need to spend some time alone and
focus on myself take all the time you
need
hi there hello
janet who's that man this is my new
rebound boyfriend derek i made him
hi i'm derek you must be mike ah
okay that makes more sense you must be
michael janet's made a lot of talk talk
into my ear holes about you michael
michael michael kleichel quickly
janet you can't make a person i know but
i did though eleanor said that to forget
about jason i should create a rebound
guy so i made one derek i'm her
boyfriend and she made me he's so nice
whoa look at this glass oh my god
i'm in there too
what's going on right now it's my first
time making someone so he might be a
little bit off look this could be please
put that down this could be very
dangerous it shouldn't even be possible
well maybe not 800 reboots ago but
apparently now it is
[Music]
can you believe this derek is it derek
it's derek derrick could you please give
me and janet a moment alone go back to
the void babe i'll be there in a minute
okay i'll miss you like crazy i'll miss
you more no
i'll miss you more bye
what a dork am i right
ugh
jason jason jason jason jason
jason jason jason jason jason jason uh
jason jason jason jason jason jason
jason
don't be jealous
i love you now oh we are gonna spend
every second together no no no you are
not janet no one can know about
i'm so sorry what's your name again
derek hostetler if anybody finds out
about him we are doomed he has to stay
in your void it's our void now
we moved in together what can you
believe it i got my own hanger for my
jumpsuit you're ready i mean that's
that's so fast well when you know you
know
and we know literally everything we are
so in sync we're finishing each other
derek
well well well
jason mendoza at last we meet you've got
a lot of nerve buddy no no i'm eleanor
man
everybody this is derek janet made derek
as a boyfriend to try and rebound from
jason
oh i feel quite light-headed
janet fetch my tizzy couch please
there's no easy way to say this
i never should have made you
i think it's time for you to go away i
understand
because you understand
janet this relationship has been the
best seven hours of my whole life it's
been the only seven hours of my whole
life i made you this morning we all
remember okay you ready to do this yep
janet
what are you doing i imbued derek with
some of my thoughts and emotions this is
the only way i could reabsorb them it'll
just be a minute
dang it that is some hot reabsorbing can
you get pregnant from reabsorbing
uh oh i hear wind chimes look away
everybody look away i'm gonna keep
watching but you guys look
who are you derek
thanks for helping us all those times we
showed up to repay you here's a willing
sex robot and two duffel bags full of
cocaine there are wind chimes where my
ding-dong should be
[Music]
i can work with that all right don't
think of derek as my ex-boyfriend i made
him so he's more like my son
although i did make him because i was
jealous of you and tahani so he's kind
of my rebound booty call so he's your
son rebound booty call fine if you want
to put labels on it i guess he's my son
rebound booty call
but he doesn't mean anything to me
also derek never really
worked right he's a buffoon you have
nothing to worry about
how should he love thee or how deemed he
wise who would not leave him in his
wandering
oh
i didn't see you there i was just
reciting some edgar allen poe hi
i'm derek
welcome to the medium place
derek
you have mindy to thank for that
see she found a plunger sticking out of
the ground behind our house and every
time she hits it i pass out when i come
to i'm a little bit smarter and a little
bit better not to brag but i almost have
a full-grown penis now it's resplendent
and mostly functional how many times has
mindy rebooted you i don't know half a
million what she reboots me a lot
sometimes when she's bored or just needs
some alone time sometimes just for
laughs
derek
shall we head inside okay
cool would anybody like a medium snack i
myself will be enjoying another classy
martini don't mind if i do
i can make the people
just like i made derek are you sure yes
if the judge restores my powers in the
medium place i can do it they'll be way
more advanced than the original derrick
no offense none taken
okay the other residents will be
comprised of janet babies you will have
one year of earth time to try to improve
the humans i will be monitoring
everything to ensure there's no cheating
and to track the human's progress
deal
can't help but notice you're making a
bunch of people
you know if we pooled our resources we
could be done in two shakes of a lamb's
derrick whatever janet doesn't need your
help dude actually it would go a lot
faster thanks derek no problem
don't worry this is purely professional
okay i'll be a pal and hold my classy
martini while i get down to business
let's make people
[Music]
i love you
and you don't need to respond cause
i know you have trouble saying how you
feel i love you too
[Music]
knock knock knock
no
hey what's up can i talk to you for a
sec
yeah sure why not
hey derek yes mindy what can derek do
for you uh eleanor and i are gonna talk
for a bit so go into your nethersphere
that's derrick mindy has rebooted derek
more than
151 million times derek is now both a
singular point in space and yet derek
also contains space itself the nexus of
derek is without dimension the moment of
derek's creation and the eventual heat
death of the universe are now inexorably
the same ugh you are so annoying
want a beer
you